for men especially we have this bravado
where we feel like we can't be
vulnerable vulnerability was one of the
biggest tools that help me break through
some of the ego you know in Buddhism
they say diamond cutting cutting through
the rough cutting to the core so for me
vulnerability was that vulnerability was
that tool for me to cut that diamond in
the rough and the more vulnerable I was
the more things became liberating and I
think
if you can let go of the ego or strip
away that onion of that ego cuz we still
all have it
insecurity uh not feeling that you're
valued all these things are all part of
it but you have to let it go cuz if you
don't let it go it's going to become a
big old bag backpack on your back and it
gets heavier and heavier and heavier and
it breaks you down physically as well as
spiritually